hola cómo les va en realidad por una
cuestión de edad porque me duele la
espalda
no estoy conmovido así que bueno sepan
disculparme si está bien la altura bueno
el objetivo de esta charla es
es la primera vez que hablo de malvinas
en público pero nunca me gustó el tema
de malvinas tratarlos desde la lástima o
desde el dolor y por eso el objetivo de
hoy es darle otra mirada por eso lo
pusimos en la presentación como una una
mirada positiva se le puede sacar cosas
positivas a sobrevivir una guerra de
hecho muchos de los veteranos lo hemos
logrado en que la charla voy a tratar de
instrumentar la primero la experiencia
personal espero que les sirva pero el
objetivo es cómo extraer ciertas cosas
de la vivencia para liderar proyectos y
lograrlo con determinado éxito porque me
vas controlando el tiempo no es el medio
lata
bueno que me pasó desde los 18 a los a
los 30 va al final que es la experiencia
post malvina la parte más dura después
una vez que me hacen temer este empiezo
a trabajar en la industria portuaria por
cuestiones de trabajo empiezo a liderar
un proyecto grande de una obra un dique
que está aquí la escollera después
y compito para sacar una beca y me voy a
trabajar españa y en españa empieza a
observar
palabras como planificación y estrategia
todas las empresas portuarias son
públicas y todas las empresas públicas
españolas están planificando a 10 años a
15 años para mí era ciencia oculta
porque nosotros casi amo todo lo indio
con una gran viveza criolla como que
todos lo hacíamos con una pasión y una
intuición desenfrenada por supuesto que
las cosas no salían horribles de hecho
nosotros teníamos en el puerto que era
la empresa en la cual yo estaba
trabajando en ese momento muy mala fama
en el mundo en el mercado internacional
y en el mercado argentino entonces me
llamó la atención esa palabra estrategia
y planificación ahora fíjense en el
ambiente portuario se planifica porque
las obras son muy costosas es decir una
obra de cien millones de dólares no se
puede pensar en dos semanas hay que
lleva un tiempo de trabajo un tiempo de
buscar el financiamiento y un tiempo de
realización es decir hay que planificar
sí o sí pero hay a las empresas les
estoy hablando por en el 2005 fue cuando
esta experiencia planificaban todo hacia
donde querían ir su administración su
estructura de personal a 10 años a 12
años manuales la verdad que cuando
vuelvo a la argentina aplicamos eso en
el puerto de hecho debe haber algunos
portuarios aquí y nos fue muy bien
empezamos a pensar para que trabajaba el
puerto en el puerto nosotros no sabíamos
para quien trabajamos nunca lo habíamos
pensado porque andaba igual a funcionar
anda pensamos que detectamos el cliente
empezamos a aplicar esas técnicas de
planificación estratégica por cuestiones
de la vida también me presentó en una
beca en eeuu me voy a eeuu estudiar
termino haciendo un posgrado nuevamente
en estados unidos observó estrategias
pero desde otro ángulo se planificaba
más comercialmente pero siempre pensando
a diez años a cinco años con mecanismos
muy comerciales muy muy agresivos el
objetivo es vender es decir que en el
primer mundo se planificaba y se pensaba
diez o quince años entonces en ese en
ese país me encuentro con un libro y ahí
empiezo a asociarlo con el tema de
malvinas por eso lo mezclé en esta
charla para no ver la parte fea
porque no es el objetivo buenos los
tristes sino que saquen algo de esto de
cómo hacer algo exitoso si es que nos
gusta el libro se llama es el arte de la
guerra es un libro que se escribió
escribió un general chino es un zoom en
el año 500 aproximadamente antes de
cristo es y que el libro tiene 2.500
años y son 13 capítulos se los
recomiendo está en internet se puede
bajar tranquilamente y en los 13
capítulos hay frases de cómo ganar una
batalla sobre todo una estrategia la
estrategia bélica para ganar todas las
frases gran parte de ese libro se
utiliza en el gerenciamiento empresarial
ahora
por ejemplo en el libro se dice antes de
hacer un movimiento reflexiona todo todo
el libro sea si son frases de estrategia
de filosofía para la guerra bueno pero
ahí me encuentro con que es comparable
la guerra con la competencia qué es lo
que pasa ya no haya se habla de por
ejemplo hoy estamos hablando de la
guerra entre chile / perdón entre eeuu y
china que está haciendo bajar nuestro
precio de los commodities nos está
afectando muchísimo la guerra entre
amazon y alibaba la empresa china o sea
ellos hablan de guerra como un problema
comercial les puedo asegurar que no es
lo mismo pero hay frases que se podrían
hacer mejor vamos a tratar de superar el
tema de la guerra y hablemos de lo que
es si quieren ustedes gerenciar una
empresa cuando se habla de ejército se
habla de empresas cuando se habla de un
territorio en el en el arte de la guerra
se está hablando un mercado
ahora yo haría algunas salvedades yo le
voy a decir lo que para mí después en mi
experiencia de haber liderado empresas y
proyectos y algunos con relativo éxito
no es el éxito económico a lo que me
estoy refiriendo cuando me refiero al
éxito es hacer lo que uno desea primero
hay que desearlo y después hay que
hacerlo yo me siento bien cuando logro
eso no si gano más dinero menos si logro
hacer lo que pensé o planifique hacer
qué pasa cuando uno ve todo estos cursos
que yo les comento ahí yo quisiera hacer
cuatro salvedades antes de entrar en el
punto primero somos sociedades
diferentes es decir en el primer mundo
el éxito para ellos es una virtud a
nosotros el éxito nos da un poquito de
vergüenza
si es el éxito para nosotros está
asociado a cómo que eso es un egoísta la
está peleando vos sos un tipo la
verdad el tipo éxito es un tipo
allá no vaya para ello el éxito es un
valor ellos luchan por el éxito a los
chicos desde los 5 años están juntando
dinero para ver cómo hacen para estudiar
para que tenga una carrera universitaria
para que tenga éxito todos éxitos y si
no sos exitoso atento no es como acá acá
hay cobertura para los que somos medios
fracasados allá no vaya quedas tirado en
la calle
otra segundo cuestión que yo quisiera
diferenciar entre una cosa y la otra que
son las empresas ya cuando se habla de
que las empresas de que vamos en las
empresas libres estamos hablando de
empresas que tienen más potencia que un
estado son empresas globales se mueven
en todo el mundo ellos si pelean en
territorio mercado pero al fin y al cabo
son territorio las empresas en la
argentina están destrozadas son empresas
chicas el mercado es muy chico
generalmente son monopolios porque aquí
no hay un mercado perfecto generalmente
asociada al estado de alguna manera para
buscar un favorcito las empresas las más
grandes siempre tienen alguna relación
con el estado en nuestro país sobre todo
en los países donde el mercado no está
desarrollado les hablo de mercado a la
compra y la venta entonces nuestro país
o gerenciar una empresa y tomar estos
manuales hay que hacer estas salvedades
y después
nosotros como sociedad para nosotros que
es importante el asado somos distintos
entonces pero nos gusta el éxito sí que
nos gusta el éxito a todos nos gusta
ganar bueno a mí me gusta ganar yo no le
tengo miedo a la competencia
estoy acostumbrado al fracaso fracasado
más veces que ganar pero también es
parte pero ahora
vamos si a los puntos tomados de mi
experiencia personal de todos estos
cursos que al final es que terminé
enamorándome de esos países por por como
avanzaron copiarme les recuerdo una
frase en el 2005 cuando llegó me dice
un poder de un director de un puerto
pero vasco y de otra época no supone
aplicada así se puede aplicar si por
supuesto no son iguales pero sí se
pueden aplicar hay que adaptarlas lo que
yo les decía hay que hacer algunas
diferencias pero se pueden tomar
de hecho planificar evidentemente es muy
importante en nuestro mercado bueno
vamos a los consejos que yo les daría y
si se los pueden llevar y después a lo
último vamos al tema devolviendo el
tiempo con el tema de malvinas y que
tiene que ver con todo esto
yo rescato que para liderar un proyecto
o una empresa o lo que ustedes quieran
lo primero que tenemos que hacer es
tener pasión
y uno no tiene pasión no tiene energía y
ese fuego interno para hacer las cosas
yo le diría que ni siquiera lo intente
ahora si uno tiene la pasión a veces la
pasión no es ser líder porque en un
grupo no todos somos uno a veces se
puede ser el último se puede ser
suplente en el equipo pero hay que
querer estar hay que tener ganas de
estar primer punto pasión
segundo tema y esto sí es más técnico
hay que hacer una planificación en
nuestro país espero que sí dejemos de
hablar de la planificación como un
discurso que se utiliza generalmente en
estas épocas
ustedes saben a lo que me refiero y
después no se planifica nada entonces de
hecho así nos está yendo como les hablo
como empresario como profesional y como
líder de algunos proyectos sociales no
hay planificación por lo tanto hay que
planificar hay que planificar tercer
punto
asociado la planificación hay que hacer
un análisis mínimo la vives aquí o allá
no sirve para todo
es decir en el libro en el arte de la
guerra dice si si tú y tu enemigo son
ignorantes está hace el peligro está
asegurado es decir no les digo que hay
que ser ingeniero nuclear para hacer una
estrategia pero más o menos hay que
ponerse a pensar escribir en un
cuadernito tampoco ni siquiera una
computadora se necesita ustedes pueden
agarrar desiguales yuki lo sé yo quiero
llegar hasta el punto estrategia no voy
a planificar llegar a estallar cómo hago
para llegar hasta el final hasta allá
hasta el hasta el local puedo encarar
derecho por acá y romper todo o puedo
pensar si puedo ir por los caminos
laterales voy a tardar un poco más pero
me parece que va a ser menos
es decir bueno hay técnicas yo quiero
hacerlo lo más sencillo que puedo hay
técnica los americanos tienen muchísimas
técnicas para analizar una estrategia
los europeos también los españoles más
acá por supuesto lo leemos no aplicamos
mucho
uno de ellos es el foda es analizar
nuestra virtud de nuestros defectos
nuestras debilidades volcarlas en un
papel y ahí sí tirarnos un camino por
qué por qué tirar una estrategia de un
objetivo sin analizarlo podemos poner un
objetivo inalcanzable si nos analizamos
primero porque capaz que no puedo llegar
hasta allá de hecho por ejemplo el yo no
puedo ser emperador en china imposible
entonces porque si lo analizo un poquito
el cuarto punto es muy fundamento que es
fundamental es el factor humano y el
liderazgo
está asociado a las ganas y a la pasión
es líder es importante tiene que haber
en los proyectos y en las empresas un
liderazgo no existe el trabajo en
asamblea porque hay veces que hay que
tomar decisiones el liderazgo surge del
más apasionado generalmente el que más
ahora le mete que generalmente y el que
tiene esa visión que sabe cómo llegar
ordena el equipo tiene que haber el
liderazgo y tiene que haber un equipo de
trabajo no se puede hacer con un
amontonamiento del amontonamiento sirve
para jugar a la mancha ver todo lo que
ésta ha jugado eso no es trabajo en
equipo trabajo en equipo tiene que ser
orgánico tiene que tener cierta
disciplina hay que poner un objetivo es
decir espero y siguiendo el hilo de la
charla fíjense que vamos pensando en
pasión hay que planificar hay que
analizar y hay que tener factor humano
no cualquiera sirve para cualquier cosa
y aunque parezca duro nosotros estamos
acostumbrados en nuestros ambientes en
un país quizás de tercer mundo donde
generalmente se asciende por acomodo y
se ingresa por conocimiento conocimiento
del jefe no conocimiento propio bueno
eso no es muy saludable y el quinto
punto a las estrategias los análisis hay
que analizarlos cada ocho meses un año
en nuestro país otra cuestión que dice
el libro el arte de la guerra en el caos
existe una oportunidad y salió esa frase
lo escribió en chino hace 2500 en el
caos de la guerra de la batalla hay
oportunidades de vencer en nuestro país
y ustedes saben que es un caos constante
o sea cada cuatro años esto se da vuelta
cada ocho por lo tanto la planificación
que podemos hacer les recomiendo que
nunca supere los cinco años y que cada
uno año entre 8 y 12 meses hay que hacer
una revisión y ahora voy con el tiempo
bueno perfecto ahora como lo trasladamos
todas malvinas
bueno yo les quiero contar mi
experiencia de malvinas no voy a ser muy
aparte no me acuerdo mucho porque hay
como un bloqueo mental yo me acuerdo de
las cosas buenas de malvinas de lo malo
para mí ya pasó
qué pasó con mal vino bueno 18 años nos
vamos a la guerra piensen ustedes
planificación estrategia no estamos
dando un país guau
18 años lo vamos la guerra instrucción
militar un mes nunca tiene un tiro
la pistola no sabía que cargarlas el
fusil creo que tiramos cinco o seis
tiros nos dan un cañón con una
computadora tampoco sabía utilizarlo en
abril a malvinas
no sabíamos armar la carpa no sabíamos
en la trinchera no sabíamos qué tipo de
terreno teníamos por supuesto no
sabíamos disparar empiezan los
bombardeos lo primero que hacía era
tirarlo al piso pero no teníamos
entrenamiento
tuvimos la suerte de estuve la suerte de
sobrevivir pero hubo otros que no
entonces cuando pasó no nos detectó un
misil nos descubren nos tiran un misil
lamentablemente fallece en amigos no
sabíamos qué hacer cuando ve un
bombardeo no sabemos qué hacer con los
cuerpos no sabíamos qué hacer con las
heridas no sabíamos cómo miren lo que le
voy a decir la comida no llegaba no
habia logística entonces yo bajé 12
kilos ahora estoy saludable pero en
aquel momento bajé 12 kilos con 18 años
es decir que el cuerpo muy deteriorado
50 días no hay donde ir al baño no sé
que les quiero contar de esto que lo
viví en carne propia cuando alguien no
planifica pasa eso es un caso extremo el
que les estoy contando pero pasa eso
nosotros cuando estuvimos en la guerra
nos tocó era tal el desastre
organización que eran peor los amigos de
los enemigos porque había que sobrevivir
de nuestros problemas y el segundo gran
problema de la poca planificación que
tuvimos como país pero no no irme mucho
fue el retorno
tampoco planificamos el retorno de
soldados
vienen de una guerra había que tener los
hospitales preparados no sabían cómo
operar si estuve internado dos meses por
un problema en la pierna el hospital era
un caos disculpen la palabra un
despelote no sabían no sabía ni dónde
meternos también me dejaron en una cama
dos meses fue mi papá no me encontraba
en aquel momento porque no estaba
organizado nada argentinas vivís activos
entonces y para ir cerrando porque
tampoco quiero que generar emociones por
el tema de la guerra yo lo que quiero
que se rescate es que si nos ponemos las
pilas y aceptamos la estrategia la
planificación es muy fácil o mucho más
fácil llegar al éxito en cada uno de los
proyectos de ustedes bueno espero que
hayan pasado y escucharás